And now we're moving
into this agentic future,
this new frontier.
Talk to me
a little bit about how
Algorand is positioning for
that and how you guys
are building for that
agentic builder future.
There's two answers to that.
One, settling transactions on
Algorand through x402
is an incredible protocol.
This is going to power
the future of agentic commerce.
Whatever humans want their
agents to buy,
or agents want their
works really great on Algorand.
The other thing is
we built a compiler
so you can write
smart contracts in easy languages.
That also unlocks
the ability for AI
to build stuff on Algorand
because it uses a
language that LLMs know best.